>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Roberta I.
Shaffer: And today we are pleased
to be cosponsoring this event
with our sister unit, the African
Hebraic and Middle Eastern Division
of library services and you
will meet the esteemed head
of that unit a little
bit later in the program.
I just wanted to take a few
minutes to sort of set us
up for Human Rights
Day and its origins.
Most people in the audience I
don't think looking out will recall
that it was started as a universal
declaration of human rights
in the United Nations in
1948 it was in Paris however.
And it emanated from
the four freedoms
that President Franklin Delano
Roosevelt had articulated
in his 1941 State of the
Union address to Congress.
And those four freedoms which were
very, very well known by everyone
at the time were, of course, freedom
of religion, freedom of speech,
freedom from want and
freedom from fear.
Franklin Delano Roosevelt then
appointed the first lady Eleanor
to spearhead an effort
through the United Nations
to develop a universal
declaration of human rights.
And I think what's worth recalling
at this time is the
composition of the delegation.
So the delegation represented many,
many countries, Lebanon, Canada,
the UK, Chile of course,
the United States,
China, the then Soviet Union.
But what I think is even more
striking to think about in terms
of our discussions about human
rights today and then of course,
our esteem colleagues and panelists
that we will hear from shortly,
is the fact that the initial
drafters were not just lawyers
and jurists.
Among the drafters were playwrights,
art collectors, of course,
educators, diplomats, trade
unionists, a former army official
from World War One,
and a theologian.
So I'm always struck when I think
about human rights how
very interesting it was
that that initial group
that first recognized
that indeed there are universal
rights and that there, therefore,
must be universal protections
and universal ways to assure
that protections both
financial, as well as diplomatic
and perhaps even the use of force.
That it was not just the
law that set that milestone.
So I hope you will
think about that today
when you are listening
to our panelists.
The more mundane thing
I need to ask you is
to please silence your
electronic devices.
To please note that you do have
a question sheet in your program,
so if you would like to ask a
question to please write it down
and submit it to one of the
law library staff members
around the room.
There is a program survey
and it is now my pleasure
to just briefly tell you
about our wonderful moderator
and convener for today.
Jane McAuliffe is our colleague, she
is inaugural head of the National
and International Outreach
Service Unit at the Library
of Congress, a newly created unit.
She comes to this position
with an enormous resume.
Former president of Bryn Mawr
College, former Dean of arts
and sciences at Georgetown
University.
But most important, I think
for today's discussion a very,
very well respected and
prolific writer in the areas
of Islam and religious studies.
She has her doctorate
in religious studies
from the University of Toronto.
And the final thing I will do before
turning the podium over to Jane is
to ask you to please make
sure that anything you brought
in today is neatly tucked
in the seat in front of you
and that your minds are in
the open and upright position.
Jane, please take the podium.
Thank you so much for
joining us today.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Thank you Roberta.
Good morning.
Can you hear me, great?
It's my pleasure to
introduce the speakers
who will tackle this fascinating and
ever so important topic this morning
and then to moderate the panel
of discussion that will follow
after their individual
presentations.
We have for distinguished
speakers this morning
and I will do very brief
introductions of each of them
and then call them forward.
The first is our own Issam Saliba
who is a specialist in Islamic law
for the Law Library of Congress
and has been so since 2003.
He's written broadly and he's
written some very important things
on such matters as the
Saddam Hussein trial,
on international tribunals, national
crimes in the Hariri assassination,
on Lebanon its presidential
election,
and the conflicting
constitutional interpretations.
He's also written on a place of
Sharia among the legal systems
of the world, which would
probably be the very prelude
for today's discussion.
Issam Saliba also testifies before
Congress on matters relevant
to his field of Islamic law on such
matters as the Iraqi Constitution
and the laws on oil and gas
production in those areas.
So a broad range of expertise
is represented in his testimony.
Prior to coming to the Library
of Congress he practiced law
as a member of the Beirut bar
and he's also an associate member
of the District of Columbia bar.
Our next speaker will be Dr. Kristen
Stilt who's a professor of law
and co-director of the
Islamic Legal Studies program
at Harvard Law School.
Before that she was at Northwestern
as a professor of international law
at the Northwestern Law School
and is a professor of history
in the university itself.
Her JD is from the University
of Texas at Austin and her PhD
in Middle Eastern studies
and history is from Harvard.
She has had research
support from some
of the country's most
prestigious foundations,
including the Carnegie Foundation
and the Guggenheim Foundation
and has published material
which is particularly important
for our conversation.
Her book with Oxford University
Press in 2011 was Islamic Law
in Action, a journal published this
year in the International Journal
of Constitutional Law is
entitled Contextualizing
Constitutional Islam.
Her colleague at Harvard is Dr.
Intisar Rabb who is also professor
of law at Harvard Law
School and co-director
of its Islamic legal
studies program.
Doctor Rabb is also a professor of
history at Harvard and a professor
at the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Studies.
Before coming to Harvard she
taught at New York University
in their Middle Eastern
Islamic studies department
and at NYU Law School.
She's been a visiting
associate professor
in the Islamic legal studies
program at Harvard and a member
of the faculty at the
Boston College Law School.
Her bachelor's degree is
from Georgetown University,
her JD from Yale and bot her
MA and PhDs are from Princeton.
Dr. Rabb was a law clerk
for Judge Thomas Ambro
of the United States Court of
Appeals for the Third Circuit.
She too has been supported by
major foundations in this country,
including the Carnegie
Foundation and the Beckman Center
for Internet and Society at Harvard.
Her most recent publications include
an edited volume that she did
with Michael Cook and others in
2013, entitled Law and Tradition
in Classic Islam, as well as her
own monograph Doubt in Islamic Law
that was published this year
by Cambridge University Press.
And finally we have Dr. Sherman
Jackson who is the King Faisal Chair
of Islamic thought and culture
and has been so since 2011.
This is the first and the oldest
endowed chair in Islamic studies
in the United States, it's at the
University of Southern California.
Sherman is in Southern
California now, but he has been
in many other places including
University of Texas at Austin,
Indiana University, Wayne State
and the University of Michigan.
His PhD, however, is from the
University of Pennsylvania,
so he has East Coast roots.
His publication list is too long for
me to read every single one of them,
but they come in an
amazing range of material.
Most recent book is entitled
Initiative to Stop the Violence,
Sadat's Assassins and the
Renunciation of Political Violence
that Yale published last year.
He has written on Sufism,
he's written on Islam
in the black American and Islam
and the problem of black suffering
and several other books
on Islamic law.
He's currently working on a book
called Beyond Good and Evil Sharia
and the challenge of
the Islamic Secular.
Each of our speakers has 15 minutes.
We will keep the four
presentations to an hour.
I will do kind of diplomatic
timing, but will also rely
on my colleagues to
be good citizens.
So with that I welcome
Issam Saliba to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Issam M. Saliba: Thank
you Jane, good morning.
Islamic law is a legal system of
special characteristics described
by the late Joseph Schacht
Introduction to Islamic Law.
At the epitome of Islamic thought
the most typical manifestation
of the Islamic way of life, the
core and kernel of Islam itself.
Unlike its counterparts in the
west Islamic law regulates acts
of worship and religious
rituals [inaudible].
And acts of regular
transactions or [inaudible].
The purpose of this presentation is
to inquire whether the reformation
of the law of Muamalat
and not the law
of any particular state is possible
from within the Islamic
legal theory.
The Islamic legal theory is based on
immoral concept of right and wrong
or good and bad under which the
law mandates the performance
of what is good and
forbids the performance
of what is bad of the human acts.
Back in the 1950's, the late US
Supreme Court Justice Robert Jackson
captured the essence of this
theory by pointing out that
under American law in
contrast to Islamic law one may
at the same time be
a law-abiding citizen
and a totally shabby character.
The majority of Muslim scholars
who organizing to schools
of Islamic legal thought
or [inaudible] argued
that a human reason cannot on
its own gain knowledge of the law
because it's determination
of the goodness and badness
of human acts is relative and
with the changing identity
of the person making
the determination.
To illustrate this point Abu
?amid Mu?ammad Al Ghazali,
the 12 century Muslim
scholar gives in his book.
[ Foreign Language Being Spoken ]
The example of killing a king.
He states that the act of
killing is considered a good act
by the King's enemies and a
bad act by his supporters.
Muslims believe the sharia
consisting of the divine commands
of God regulates all
aspects of the human conduct,
including in the field
of legal relations.
What God describes
is necessarily good.
What God forbids or
proscribes is necessarily bad.
The Quran, the holy book of
Islam, and the traditions
or the prophet Mohammed
contain the divine commands
and are the primary
source of the law.
The Sunnah was transmitted
through order reports
or [inaudible] before
being collected
into what is known
as Books of Hadith.
God's prescriptions and
proscriptions are rarely
if at all readily identifiable
as legal rules.
For example, verse 590 of
the Quran warns the believers
against gambling and against wine.
The meaning is relatively clear,
gambling and wine are prohibited.
But it is not clear one,
whether these prohibitions
entail worldly punishments.
Two, whether the punishments
are civil or criminal.
And three, whether the two
prohibitions have the same
legal consequences.
To deal with such questions the
school has developed a specialized
discipline of study
known as [inaudible]
or science of understanding.
[Inaudible] gives a human
reason, the prominent role
of interpreting the divine commands
to derive the legal rules using
the utmost intellectual efforts
in a process called Ijtihad.
In [inaudible] Al Ghazali states
that [inaudible] is among
the most noble sciences why?
Because it is the place where reason
and revelation conjoin and opinion
and divine commands coalesce.
Through Ijtihad the schools
interpreted verse 590
to derive two different rules.
One making the consumption of wine
or any other intoxicants
a criminal act punishable
by a number of lashes.
The other making gambling a grave
sin for which expiation is due.
The totality of the
interpretations produced
by the schools during
a formative period
of about 300 years constitutes
what we call today sharia law
or Islamic law.
Even though it has according to
Justice Jackson an amazing record
of accomplishments, Islamic law
has been stagnant for a long time
and some of its rules are
incompatible with modern norms.
A Muslim who abandons
Islam is still subject
to the death penalty notwithstanding
his [inaudible] right
to believe or not to believe.
A Jew is still required
to convert to Islam
or pay the jizya notwithstanding the
instructions of the prophet Mohammed
that no Jew shall be
enticed to leave Judaism.
And the [inaudible] faith
is still the confessed form
of government notwithstanding
the silence
of the Quran on this subject.
Three questions are
relevant to our inquiry.
First, is Islamic law immutable?
The majority of Muslims appear
to believe in the immutability
of Islamic law by refusing
to critically discuss past
interpretation of sharia.
In his book The Reconstruction of
Religious Thought in Islam published
in 1930 Muhammad Iqbal referring to
millions of Muslims in India writes,
unfortunately, the conservative
Muslim public of this country is not
yet quite ready for a critical
discussion of [inaudible],
which if undertaken is likely
to displease most people
and raise sectarian controversies.
Attempts at legal reforms undertaken
by self-proclaimed Muslim states
have largely gone backward.
In the 1990's Nasr Hamid Abu Zayd,
an Egyptian professor was
judicially declared [inaudible]
because of his academic writings.
And as a result his marriage to
his Muslim wife was nullified.
Going back to the Islamic
legal theory, we find no basis
for the belief in the
immutability of the law
as interpreted by the schools.
None of the schools has ever
claimed finality or exclusivity
of its interpretations of sharia.
Imam Abu Hanifa [inaudible]
is reported to have said,
our ruling is an opinion,
the best we could attain.
Whoever comes with a better
option deserves our support.
And the Islamic [inaudible] there is
room for different interpretations
to coexist and by extension for such
interpretations to evolve or change.
In one [inaudible] Prophet
Muhammad is reported to have said,
the disagreement of my
community is a blessing.
The Islamic legal theory itself
recognizes the evolving nature
of Islamic law by adopting the
maxim that states there is denying
that the changes in times
lead to changes in law.
It incumbent upon the Muslim
polity to realize that the law
as formulated by the schools
during the early centuries
of Islam is not impervious
to change.
Second, can the sharia support
the new interpretations?
The universal principles and
values of sharia, such as justice,
equality, and the public
interest not only support but call
in my opinion
for new interpretations
of the divine commands.
[Inaudible], a Muslim scholar who
died around 1316 argues in one
of his writings that the principle
of public interest is the ultimate
guide in deriving the legal rules
of sharia and should be
given precedence even
over contrary statements
of the divine text.
In his collection of fataawas
[inaudible] the renowned 14th
century Muslim scholar
quotes approvingly
that God would support a just
government of unbelievers,
meaning unMuslims and would not
support an unjust government
of believers meaning Muslims.
In 1925, Ali Abdel Raziq, a
faculty member of Islamic University
of Al-Azhar published a book
titled, Islam and the Foundation
of Governance in which he relies
on divine sources to conclude
that sharia gives the Muslim
polity the right to adopt the form
of government most
suitable to its needs.
If the Sunni Muslim polity
ideas with [inaudible]
and Ali Abdel Raziq there is no
doubt that the political theory
of the caliphate would undergo a
dramatic reformation from within.
And lead to the establishment of a
modern government without the need
for assistance from
us here in the west.
In the reconstruction of religious
thought Muhammad Iqbal writes the
republican form of government is
not the only authority consistent
with the spirit of Islam, but has
also become a necessity in view
of the new forces that are
set free in the word of Islam.
Because of his belief in
the compatibility of Islam
with modern government Sheikh
Muhammad Abdu, the great reformer
of the 19th century has allegedly
said after visiting friends.
In France I saw Islam
I didn't see Muslims.
In Egypt I see Muslims
I don't see Islam.
My colleagues on this
panel may have more to say
about how specific interpretations
of sharia would support
through reformation.
Third, who has the authority
to reform Islamic law?
To answer this question we need
to go back to the formative period
and find out how the work of the
various schools was legitimized
into becoming a binding law.
The schools did not have any
authority in this regard.
None of the schools had any official
status, representative capacity
or legislative mandate to decide
on what the law is or isn't.
They all came into existence
on their own initiative
and acted independently
from and at times
in confrontation with the state.
The authority that legitimized
the law as formulated
by the schools was the
authority of the Muslim people.
Schools that did not garner the
consent of the people disappeared
and their interpretations of the
divine commands never became law.
Among the many schools that came
into existence only the work
of a few got the support
needed to become binding law.
The authority of the Muslim
polity as the legitimizing factor
of Islamic law has been enshrined in
the doctrine of Ijma or consensus.
And that this doctrine the
consensus of the Muslim polity
on a legal matter not
only legitimizes
that legal rule resulting therefrom,
but constitutes an original source
of the legal rules themselves.
As a consequence, the Muslim polity
not the Muslim scholars has the
authority to reform Islamic law.
In concluding, it is
reasonable to wonder
if the Islamic legal theory
allows for the reformation
of Islamic law from within.
Why haven't such reformations
materialized?
The essence of the answer
given by Muhammed Iqbal early
in the last century is
probably still valid today.
The conservative Muslim public
is still not yet quite ready
for a critical discussion of the
past interpretation of sharia.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Kristen A. Stilt: Thank you to
Dr. Saliba and to Kimberly Zellars
and everyone here at the Library
of Congress for this invitation
to be here on or in honor of
I should say Human Rights Day.
We have a few more days until
Human Rights Day itself.
I am very pleased to be here with
such distinguished colleagues.
And today I'll be focusing on family
law in this short presentation.
So family law in Muslim majority
countries has undergone tremendous
change over the past century
and this change continues today
with intensity and controversy.
And change can happen in many ways
and can be led by many
types of actors.
But today I'm talking about
when actors such as legislators
or activists or monarchs want to
change family law with the intention
of improving the rights
of women and children.
And in general, this change has
sought to adopt national laws
that would modify the rules of
Islamic law that had been applicable
and predominant in that
particular country.
And these efforts and
I'll call them reforms
because that's the term the
actors use themselves have focused
on a number of areas in particular.
So substantively, these efforts
have aimed at placing restrictions
on a husband's right to enter
into a polygamous marriage,
limiting a husband's right
to unilaterally declare his wife
divorced, extending a mother's right
to custody of the children
and be compensated for it
by her ex-husband, raising
the minimum marriage age,
expanding a wife's ability to get
a divorce at her own initiative
and requiring a husband
to compensate his wife
if he arbitrarily divorces her.
So in some Muslim majority countries
and we'll take Turkey as the example
of this, major modification of
the family law have been made
by essentially adopting
secular codes.
In doing so in Turkey for example,
Turkey operated in the context
of its form of secularism as
enshrined in its constitution
and did not attempt to justify
any of its changes as compatible
with Islamic law in any way.
But in most Muslim
majority countries,
the rules of Islamic law
are particularly relevant
in the area of family law.
And so the change process or
the reform process takes place
within this space and changes are
presented as taking place internally
to Islamic law rather than
something external to it.
So just to be clear
what I mean by that.
This may be in a country for
which religious law is not part
of other areas of the law like
business law or criminal law
or international law, but family
law often remains a domain
where there's a belief
that it is Islamic law
and that it should remain that way.
That belief is somewhat problematic
and we can talk about that later.
So the reasons for this internal
approach range from faith-based
to pragmatic, including the personal
beliefs of advocates and lawmakers
and concerns over the lack of
popular acceptance of a family law
that appears to be western
or secular in origin.
And so my talk today will focus
very briefly on two changes
in Sunni family law and how
those changes have been presented
or justified to strategies.
My focus in this project from which
this short presentation is derived
is focused mainly on the Arab
Sunni world, but we can talk beyond
that later if you would like.
So one when more preliminary
comment.
I think we want to think and
talk about what is gained
and what is lost when family
law in a country is seen
as the exclusive domain
of Islamic law.
It tends to mean that when an
advocacy organization sees a social
need for a change they
have to carefully think
about whether they can
justify it in Islamic terms.
But of course if they can
the potential for acceptance
of the change can be much higher.
But, of course, many of these
countries have signed international
human rights treaties, such as
the convention on the elimination
of all forms of discrimination
against women or CEDAW.
Although, sometimes they have put
reservations with those treaties.
And advocacy groups might be
very active in conversations
about human rights treaties
like CEDAW and see them
as setting important
benchmarks or goals.
But is the fact that a
country's laws are not compatible
with CEDAW off for example, on its
own enough to garner the initiative
to change the law and
that's the big question.
And the answer is probably
not for many places.
An exhaustive study
of Morocco and Jordan
that a scholar has just
completed she noted quote,
despite women's groups questioning
that family law should be
or indeed is Islamic law publicly,
they still have to recognize
that family law is Islamic law,
which limits the possible arguments
that can be used to
advance their claims.
So with that background I just
want to cover two areas of the law
and show you what the change was
and then how it was
justified in Islamic terms.
And the first one is polygamy
and the strategy that's been
used is essentially taking powers
that were left in the hands of
individuals and the husbands
in particular and assigning
that power to a judge.
So few Muslim majority countries
have abolished polygamy as a matter
of national law, but most attempt
to curtail the rights of a husband
to enter into a polygamous marriage.
And they place emphasis
on the Quranic verse
that requires equitable
treatment among wives.
Quote, then marry from among other
women, such as are lawful to you,
two, three or four, but
if you have reason to fear
that you might not
be able to treat them
with equal fairness that only one.
And that verse seems to speak
to a man and cautions him.
Yet another verse says, no it's
not possible to do that quote
and it will not be within
your power to treat your wives
with equal fairness,
however, you may desire it.
And so do not allow yourselves
to incline towards the exclusion
to one exclusion of the other
leaving her in a state of having
and not having a husband.
I just paraphrased there.
So many countries have adopted laws
that essentially require the husband
to go to the judge and
not leave that decision
about equal treatment
up to the individual.
Morocco adopted this approach
in 2004 in its family law code
that many you might
be familiar with.
In the preamble the Moroccan king
said he would not allow outlaw
polygamy due to his belief
that it is permissible.
But he said that polygamous
marriages would only be allowed
under compelling circumstances
and stringent restrictions
with the judge's authorization.
The judge must verify that
the husband has the means
and there must be an exceptional
mode of justifying polygamy
and this perspective second
wife must know and must consent
to the polygamist marriage.
Most recently in Jordan the
Jordanian Women's Union officially
opposed polygamy, but
they were afraid
that they wouldn't achieve
that in the 2010 law.
And so they instead proposed
judicial oversight along the same
lines as what was done in Morocco.
So notice how this strategy
works, it does not attempt
to declare polygamy impermissible
or even illegal in the state,
but instead uses those verses
to say to the husband more
or less we don't think you're
the one that should decide
and the judge will
be the one to do it.
But I should note that even
that strategy has been seen
as too controversial
in some countries.
So the next area, the second
area quickly is the area
of marriage contracts.
And the strategy here is something
I call encouraging the permissible.
So this strategy recognizes
that a gap exists
between what's permissible
as a matter of Islamic law
and what reformers think they can
actually require as state law.
And so they try to approximate
state law by encouraging people
to take advantage of
options they already have.
And so on one level this is sort
of like know your rights campaign,
but the more you can encourage
something the more it would be
potentially taken up by individuals
the more you can approximate
something like national law.
And so a good example of
this comes from Jordan.
So marriage contracts can contain
additional stipulations as long
as they don't undercut the
essence of the contract itself.
So the Jordanian laws of 1976
and 2010 specifically
identify conditions or clauses
in the contract that are
considered acceptable
and would be upheld
by a Jordanian court.
These include for example,
requiring the husband not
to take another wife, not to
prevent the wife from working,
not to require her to move
to a place she doesn't want
and giving her the right
to divorce herself.
And so the activists felt that
they were not able to achieve
that as a matter of
national law for example,
without anything else spoken
about in the contract the
husband do those things.
But by mentioning these in the
law there's an implicit statement,
you can do this, you can
put this into your contract
and the state will uphold that.
But in contrast, Egypt was not
able to go down that same path.
So while women may add
stipulations in their contract
and that's not a problem at all
what activists had wanted was a way
in which to make it known to women
here's conditions you can put in.
These the state will uphold and your
contract will not be considered null
and void as a result.
And so a coalition
drafted a marriage contract
that not only included a blank space
where these stipulations could be
written in, but also listed a number
of questions that the notary was
supposed to ask the couple helping
to perhaps prompt them to
consider these conditions.
And the questions included
speaking to the husband,
do you agree to abstain from
marrying an additional wife
and if you do so, do you agree
that your wife will have the
right to divorce herself.
And so by posing questions like
this to the husband in a yes
or no way the idea was at that
moment when the couple is filling
out this marriage contract the
woman would understand she could ask
for this and the husband would
have to essentially say no
if he didn't want that to be
included in the marriage contract.
And so the Egyptian government
actually supported this new marriage
contract that would have
these prompting questions
and sought the opinions of
religious scholars on it.
One of the highest
religious officials in Egypt,
the Sheikh of al-Azhar actually
rejected this proposed marriage
contract and he said while
it's lawful for the woman
to achieve these conditions in her
contract it should not be encouraged
as a matter of state law.
And he said it violated a concept
of the husband's superiority
or authority over the
particular -- over the woman.
And so the rejection of the standard
contract is essentially a rejection
of that strategy of
encouraging the permissible,
at least in that particular context.
So the stipulation is permissible
according to the religious leader
who essentially who said
he wouldn't support it.
But encouraging it through the
national marriage registration
process was not according to him.
So just to sum up this strategy
of encouraging the permissible it
is distinct from a national law
that would require that
result on every individual.
It would leave it to the individuals
to adopt it or not to adopt it,
but the extent of encouragement
could come close
to approximating a national law
if indeed everyone adopted it.
But it's easier, it's more palatable
because it doesn't raise
the same level of opposition
as perhaps a national law that
would prevent polygamy for example,
to go back to the example
I started with.
So in being mindful of my precise
time limits I've given you here just
two areas of law, polygamous
marriages
and then marriage contracts and
marital relations more generally,
along with a strategy that went
along with each particular area.
Encouraging the permissible
and delegating authority
to a judge or other official.
This comes from a larger work I have
in which I discuss nine strategies
across a wide array of
substantive areas of family law
and can certainly talk about that
later or send anyone the paper
if this is a concern of yours.
But given that our context today is
Human Rights Day I want an echo an
issue I mentioned at the outset.
So one of the goals of this
project of identifying strategies is
to contribute to a larger
conversation about the benefits
and disadvantages of using
strategies rooted in Islamic law
in comparison with other
ways that could be used
to achieve improvements in this
case for women and children
in the context of family law.
And of course, a prominent other
source of law or change comes
from the convention on the rights of
women as I mentioned at the outset.
So I just leave us
with four questions
that I hope we can talk about.
So the first is what is gained
and what is lost when family law
in a particular country is seen as
the exclusive domain of Islamic law.
And what is gained and what is
lost and from who's perspective.
Secondly, what is gained and what
is lost when Islamic arguments
on family law are particularly
relevant in a society and what
if they're the only relevant
argument in a society.
The third one is how can
international human rights based
arguments become persuasive
in a context
where they have not been
very persuasive right.
What about a country or a society
or a component of a society
where the international human rights
arguments have not been considered
persuasive or even important.
And then the last one is how can
international human rights norms
and Islamic law work together
and I do think they can.
Can they be mutually reinforcing?
So let me leave with
those open-ended questions
that we can come back to.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Intisar A. Rabb: He
was handing me a pointer,
I thought about doing a PowerPoint
presentation, but I've heard
that power corrupts and
PowerPoint corrupts to a point
so I thought I'd avoid that
for right now that comes later.
I'd like to thank Issam Saliba,
Kimberly Zellars, Cliff Brown
and all the other librarians
who are here and have invited us
to inform this session
which I'm honored to join.
I'll be talking about
Islamic criminal law
through internal critique or as
related to internal critique.
And this is the talk in a
nutshell, so I'll try and say this
in 30 seconds and then you
can you ignore the rest
or you can stay tuned
for the details.
So basically I'll be talking --
I want to discuss the doctrine
of doubt in Islamic law
as a significant feature of Islamic
criminal law and make the argument
that this concept of doubt
and dynamic interpretation
that goes along with it are key
to what I'm calling a process
of internal critique that pervades
Islamic law on a meta-level
and that could lead to
positive change in criminal law.
So that's the talk in a nutshell.
So as to the details let
me start by saying a word
about why we should be interested
in the idea of internal critique,
which as I'm using it is a process
through which an illegal arena
that I'm concerned with Muslim
jurists critically assess the
rulings and applications
of Islamic law.
So they critically
assess Islamic law.
And this process tends to happen
at particular historic moments,
both medieval and modern.
And such moments might occur when
the entire system of Islamic law
and governance does not exemplify
the values it purports to espouse
or it does not serve the purpose of
ensuring law and order with respect
to a greater moral system
or it functions in a context
in which those preserving or seeking
to preserve the moral order lack
the political or legal authority
to do so, to provide
the type of individual
and institutional guidance
or governance required
for a just society.
So in short, internal critique
often follows moments of crisis,
such as the fall of Baghdad in 1258
or the fall of Baghdad in 2003.
So this moment is arguably
one such moment.
Today we might expect
to see internal critique
where there is a widespread lack
of authority, ongoing questions
about who speaks for Islam, such
questions as Issam Saliba raised.
The tragic rise of extremist
groups like ISIS who use violence
in the form of war and egregious
harsh criminal punishments
and that's something I'll focus
on in particular as a means
of social control of
gaining territory,
instilling terror all
the while claiming
that their actions are
based on early Islamic law.
So nothing could be more false.
And then the rest of the talk I
have aimed to explain what I mean
by that, not by refuting what
are simply outrageous discussions
that question whether sex, slavery
or wanton killing are sanctioned
by Islamic law they're not.
But by giving a sense of the type
of reasonable decision-making
that Islamic law does historically
sanction in areas of law
and policy in the criminal arena.
And then I want to talk about
the type of dynamic rules
that Muslim thinkers,
judges, jurists,
other scholars produced
historically with respect
to what I call a doctrine of
doubt in Islamic criminal law.
And then I'll end with a look
at some modern experiments
in Islamic criminal law
that seek to use or that
through internal critique
seek to change
or update their Islamic
criminal law codes.
And just one word about
-- one more word
about the term Islamic
critique or internal critique.
I prefer to use this term over
reform, although our title
for the talk is called
perspectives on Islamic law reform
because this is a sort of
critique that is a means
of updating Islamic law through
using Islamic legal arguments.
And this relates to what Kristen
Stilt was saying about the resonance
or salience of international
human rights norms as opposed
to Islamic legal arguments and
perhaps the end is the same
of universal or shared
values, but the articulation
of them may resonate
more in one context.
And I think internal
critique captures that better
than human rights reform.
So let's start with
what do I mean by doubt.
I want to start with an
episode from early Islamic life,
it's something that's reported in
both Sunni and Shia sources repeated
across the board and
throughout Islamic history as one
of the iconic examples of --
an illustrative example
of what should happen
in criminal law context.
So in this early episode there's
a type of early police force
in a small Arabian
town out patrolling.
And members of the patrol come
across a man in the town ruins
and he's holding a bloodstained
knife and he's standing
over another man who apparently
has just been stabbed to death.
So the patrol arrest the man
with the knife and upon arrest
that man confesses
and says I killed him.
And the suspect is brought before
Ali, who is the beloved cousin
and son-in-law of the
prophet Muhammad
who had died just a
few decades before Ali
in Islamic history is the fourth
caliph according to Sunni accounts
and the first imam,
according to Shia accounts.
So he's an authoritative early
figure and he's presiding
over criminal trials in
his capacity as leader
of the young Muslim community.
And upon hearing the defendant's
story Ali reportedly sentenced the
man to death in accordance with
the Islamic law of homicide
which accommodates the death
penalty, life for life,
unless there's commutation at the
request of the victim's family.
So before the sentence was carried
out another man rushed forward
telling the executioners don't be
so hasty, don't kill him
I did it he announced.
And Ali returned to the
condemned man incredulously well,
what made you confess to a
murder that you did not commit.
And the man explained that while
he thought Ali would never take his
word for it because all the
signs had pointed to him
as the perpetrator, but in
reality he was a butcher
who had just finished
slaughtering a cow and immediately
after the slaughter he
needed to relieve himself.
So he entered the area of the
ruins, bloody knife still in hand
and upon return he came across
the dead man and he stood
over him actually in
concern and it was then
that the patrol encountered him.
And he figured that he couldn't
plausibly avoid admitting
to the crime and so
he did so and decided
to leave the matter in God's hands.
And a second man, the
actual perpetrator,
purported actual perpetrator,
he offered a corroborating story
explaining that he was the one
who had murdered the
man for his money
and then he fled upon hearing the
sounds of the patrol approaching.
And on his way out he passed
this butcher entering the area
and watched the events unfold just
as the butcher had described them.
And once the butcher had been
content condemned to death
that man didn't want the
blood of two men on his hands.
So this episode and we can
refer to it as the case
of the falsely accused butcher,
we see that things are not
exactly always how they seem.
And it really depicts
and was used in the --
whether or not it's an actual case
and this is a case or similar cases
like it have been reported
in the Jewish tradition,
early Christian traditions,
etcetera.
So whether the case is
historically accurate in all
of its facts the point is that it
was used by Muslim jurists over time
to be a guide to how Islamic
criminal law should be applied
and critically so.
So the case depicts the
difficulties that the early
and medieval Muslim judges
faced when attempting
to apply Islamic criminal law
without the benefit of being able
to discern the facts fully, the
law fully or the morality fully
of any particular case
with any certainty.
So as for the facts here confession
or witness testimony typically
suffices to establish guilt
in Islamic criminal law, but
here Ali was presented only
with circumstantial evidence
and contradictory evidence.
So the facts didn't help and
then there was some doubt
about the facts.
As for the law or the Islamic
law of homicide the Quran
and other foundational
texts contain clear rules
about intentional murder
being the only area
for which the life
for life rule applies.
But was this intentional, the facts
didn't seem to quite point there
and so the law, therefore,
was not quite on point.
There was some doubt about
whether the law applied.
And as for morality and, therefore,
legitimacy of punishment given
scriptural commands to punish
but not do so when there was
any doubt about the facts
or the law Ali needed to stay
his hand in the interpretation
of the Muslim jurists
discussing this case.
The question is why and to what
extent and the answer is shrouded
by a tangled web if
you look at the history
that took Muslim jurists
centuries to weave and, therefore,
take some time to unravel.
And don't worry I'm
not going to take all
that time to unravel it here.
But I'll cut to the center that
based on Islamic values of justice
and fairness Muslims may doubt
an avoidance of punishment
on its basis a central pillar
of Islamic criminal law
and they expressed it in the form
of a legal maxim what
I call the doubt canon
to avoid criminal punishments
in cases of doubt,
avoid criminal punishment
in cases of doubt.
This was repeated over
and over again,
avoid criminal punishments
in cases of doubt.
So [inaudible] episodes
like this one,
the case of the falsely
accused butcher,
they occur in early Islamic sources
and Muslim jurists explain these
cases with reference to doubt.
And I want to say here for anyone
familiar with American criminal law
that the Arabic term for doubt
should shubha was a term of art.
It assumed a much more expansive
meaning than the common conception
that we have as American
lawyers of reasonable doubt,
which is largely a
fact-based concept.
So rather than representing a
principle effect [inaudible]
standard of proof the Islamic
doctrine covered factual
uncertainties, legal ambiguities,
even extralegal considerations
that I call moral doubt.
And moreover, the Islamic
doctrine of doubt corresponds
to analogous American doctrines
that are seemingly as disparate
as the principle of legality,
the presumption of innocence,
legal ambiguity and the
corresponding rule of lenity.
The requirement of proof
beyond a reasonable doubt
and lesser standards of proof,
mens rea requirements, mistake,
ignorance, impossibility, and other
potentially mitigating circumstances
and even mercy.
All of these are covered
by this term shubha.
And in addition to that there's
another uniquely Islamic aspect
or valence that also applies to
the term that comes to the floor,
something called contractual
doubt or interpretive doubt
and we can discuss those.
I hear Sherman Jackson laughing
because he knows what
these refer to.
But we can discuss those in the Q&A.
So to be sure this notion of doubt
pervading Islamic criminal law is
contrary to conventional
notions of Islamic criminal law
into the conventional practice that
we see reported about in the news.
The conventional theory posits
God as a divine lawgiver
who asserts absolute
supremacy over the law.
The classical textbook version
of Islamic legal theory posits this
idea of divine legislative supremacy
where God is the sole lawgiver
who expresses himself in the form
of a set of texts, the Quran Muslim
Scripture and the Sunnah as reports
from the prophet and the
Imams in the Shia tradition.
And there's no questioning
or interpreting really
what these texts say,
that's a conventional sort of
narrow version of Islamic law.
And the most strictly textual
version of this theory then looks
to Islamic criminal law in ways
that that you might read about.
As you know someone
steals cut off their hand.
But in point of fact Islamic
law historically favored a more
pragmatic textualist account,
meaning there's reliance on the text
and interpreted -- the text is
interpreted as lawyers do relevant
to the context in front of them
and the surrounding factors
that go into the text.
So I'll say that and I
hope we can get a chance
to talk about that more.
But I want to move next to asking
how all this is relevant today.
Islamic law is as pervasive as our
other speakers have pointed to.
Since the 1970's, some 28 countries
have introduced constitutions
with clauses referring to or
incorporating Islamic law sharia
as a source or the source of laws.
So these constitutions
have sharia clauses.
And in that same time, at least a
dozen states have adopted Islamic
penal codes or Islamic criminal law
codes as well in countries ranging
from Iran, Pakistan and Saudi
Arabia to provinces in Malaysia,
northern Nigeria and now Syria.
And more recently in the wake of the
tumultuous Arab uprisings that began
in 2010, the ongoing crisis in
Iraq because of groups like Isis,
there's a lot of uncertainty
about the status of Islamic law
or the status of justice in
these regions based on arguments
that Islamic law is being applied
in ways that make people suffer.
And the emergence of these ideas
of Islamic law has prompted more
than anything fears
of its punishments.
In fact, those punishments have come
to represent sharia itself
often we leave it untranslated
to highlight the exoticism and
the danger that it can evoke.
And on this view sharia is only
a religious code that seeks
to oppress women, amputate hands,
execute apostates and indeed,
reports of summary executions and
other types of violence on the part
of state and non-state actors
in some of these countries.
They fuel this perception, I
mean there's something to that.
So it's no wonder then that sharia
inspires fear of its spread not only
in the Muslim world,
but across the globe.
But what I want to
say is that contrary
to these ahistorical manifestations
of Islamic criminal law,
there is the history that I talked
about of the pervasiveness of doubt
and then I want to now briefly
to try to keep within time look
to a situation or situations now
where there's some internal
criticism amongst Muslims
about the Islamic criminal laws
that they see applied in ways
that promote injustice
rather than justice.
Examples of the codes that
are emerging out of this sort
of internal critique have
come up in Iran in 2013.
And I should say none of these
examples have actually been applied
they're codes that have been
drafted very, very recently.
So this is a new cutting-edge
phenomenon and it remains
to be seen what the
application will be.
For the country Iran
in 2013, Brunei in 2014
and the Maldives just earlier
this year and for the sake
of time I'll just focus on Iran.
So in Iran after the 1979 revolution
all pre-revolution criminal laws,
which were based on the
French code were abolished.
And right after the
revolution or some years
after the revolution the
criminal law was replaced
with Islamic criminal law that was
un-codified, it was finally codified
in 1883, some four years
after the revolution.
And in substance the code
followed the same basic structure
as classical Islamic criminal
law where you had a set
of fixed punishments for
violations of a limited set
of crimes called hudood laws.
You had a set of non-fixed
punishments for violations
of lesser crimes called Ta'Zir
laws or misdemeanors we might say,
I'm really simplifying here.
And then you had this
law of retaliation,
eye for an eye, tooth for a tooth.
So in big picture terms the code
generally followed that structure,
but with the rise in
political excess in executions
in Iran many Muslim jurists began to
debate the use of the death penalty
and the application
of this code itself.
And so this is the --
and these debates raised
over the course of 10, 15 years.
Those complaints from the jurors
culminated in a suspension
or moratorium on the
death penalty in 2002.
And then finally the revision of the
Islamic criminal law code in 2013.
And one of the elements that
I'll point to and again,
this is all hypothetical we
haven't seen any applications yet.
But it's a significant element in
that those critiquing the code said
that there was not enough emphasis
on procedure and in the idea
that jurists or judges don't always
know whether the facts, the law
or the moral concerns that should
go into an intelligent application
of a criminal law system, especially
an Islamic criminal system
were there.
And so they've incorporated the
doubt doctrine that looks to ensure
that the facts of the law and
the moral or the legitimacy
of the punishment is
not in question.
And they actually incorporated
the doubt doctrine
for the first time
into the new code.
This canon that says avoid criminal
punishments in cases of doubt
and exactly that formulation
is now in the new code.
It remains to be seen
how it is applied.
So I'm going to conclude.
I've tried to address both
problems and prospects for change
or updating Islamic criminal law
with respect to internal critique
and highlighted some of the
modern experimental examples.
Judges tend to appeal to and
I just want to end by saying
that why the history of doubt in
Islamic criminal law is important
to these internal critiques and to
looking forward to both the problems
and prospects that I
tried to highlight.
So judges tend to appeal to
conceptions of Islamic law drawn
from its foundational
text and understandings
from the ever authoritative founding
period we might say of Islamic law
from the 7th to 11th centuries.
And law is like that, it's tradition
bound whether we're speaking
about American or Islamic
law or most other systems.
Just as we American lawyers look
to America's founding period
for authority often Muslim jurists
look to Islam's founding period.
So the history ends up
being very important.
The local politicians and Islamists
tend to be ignorant or illiterate
of the history and
I think that adding
that to the larger
conversation could be of help
to the project of internal critique.
So what happens when jurists and
lawyers contemplate the history
and operation with a wider
expanse of sources and attention
to Islam's overarching
values and purposes?
What happens if we pay more
attention to both the problems
and the prospects endemic
to internal critique?
These are the questions
that I posit in my own work,
I pose to others working on these
issues and they are questions
that I hope to discuss
with you today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Sherman A. Jackson:
Well good morning everyone.
I want to begin by thanking
of Jane and Issam and Kimberly
and everybody who's responsible
for affording me this opportunity
to before you this morning.
But I'm really worried about time
so I'm just going to jump in.
I would like to begin with
the matter of nomenclature,
particularly the term reform.
Specifically, I would like to
underscore an important distinction
between reform as an attempt to
correct, adjust, improve, update,
edit or even add to the
enterprise of Islamic law.
A reform on the other
hand as a gesture indebted
to the Protestant Reformation.
The latter reference implies that
the problem rests fundamentally
with the basic structure,
institutionalized understandings
and interpretive methods
through which Islamic law
traditionally negotiated social,
political, economic
and cultural reality.
On this understanding meaningful
reform requires a whole scale
scrapping or at least
marginalization
of the classical tradition and its
replacement with a brand-new set
of modern methods, institutional
structures and points of departure.
To my mind, however, as attractive
as this may seem to some,
this is not the most useful
approach to reforming Islamic law,
certainly not in the long run.
And let me take a moment
here to give
at least one major reason why
I believe this to be the case.
Key to any successful reform of
Islamic law or any legal system
for that matter is the
concept and value of authority.
By this I am not referring to any
power of coercion, but more simply
to the ability to enlist the
community's assent by conveying
to them a palpable sense that it
is right for them to follow one.
Of course, in the modern
west we generally assume
that reasonableness is or should
be all the authority one needs
to enlist a community's assent.
In truth, however, there is not
one but many forms of reason
and this raises the need for an
authority beyond reason itself
to adjudicate all of
our reason debates.
In the United States speaking in
talk constitutional terms at least,
this is the U.S. Constitution.
As Americans we often disagree and
put forth all kinds of reasons for
and against positions on abortion,
affirmative action or free-speech
and we may even see our
opponents' views as unreasonable.
In the end, however, we accept
the Supreme Court's authority
to terminate these
disputes in the interest
of preserving the civic order.
In law then authority works a lot
like trumps in the game of pinochle,
I hope you know pinochle.
And to borrow the expression
of Thomas Hobbes
where there is no agreed-upon
authority clubs become trumps.
The civil order in other
words simply falls apart.
Of course, one might argue in the
case of Islam that something other
than sharia, for example
liberalism could assume the role
of authority broker.
But even beyond the
substantive problems
with such a proposition it
would take literally centuries
for such a substitution
to take place.
And in the meantime, massive,
unpredictable instability
and dislocation would
be the order of the day.
My approach to reform, therefore,
proceeds on the understanding
that reform is most effectively
achieved by engaging rather
than jettisoning the
classical tradition.
Of course, this too raises
significant problems.
To begin with there
are literally dozens
of present contemporary topics
that the classical tradition never
contemplated from stem cell research
to copyright law to
sex change operations.
Beyond this many issues in which
the classical tradition spoke
definitively for example
issues relating to women,
religious minorities
or the authority
of the Muslim ruler cry
out for reconsideration.
Here the fear is that engaging the
classical tradition will either
blind us to contemporarility or
entrap us in forms of thinking
about an arranging society from
which we desperately seek to escape.
In the brief time I have remaining,
therefore, I would like to point
to just a few features of
the classical tradition
that might give some indication
about how Islamic law might come
to terms with these
related challenges.
The first feature is actually the
easiest, namely the institution
of Ijtihad or fresh unmediated
interpretation of the sources.
Obviously, where the issue
at hand is historically
unprecedented one cannot rely
on the classical schools
of law for solutions even
through extensions by analogy.
Ijtihad in this context becomes
an obligation by default.
This is actually quite
straightforward from the perspective
of the classical tradition.
Modern Muslims, however, often
invents a certain diffidence
or even hostility towards Ijtihad.
This is less a question
though of Ijtihad's status
as a legitimate approach
to sharia than it is a sort
of resentment towards the sense
that it is largely western modernity
that is generating the need
for Ijtihad to begin with.
With time of course, such
feelings can only dissipate.
In fact, I would hazard that a good
deal of Ijtihad is likely to emerge
out of those Muslim communities from
whom western reality is not imposed
or sensed as being imposed,
but is rather the only
reality they have ever known.
But what may be difficult to imagine
in the present moment this points
to the importance of western
Muslim communities and the future
or to the future of Islamic law.
Now having said this much, Ijtihad
remains limited in its utility.
For many of the most
problematic features
of Islamic law are
precisely those rules
that the classical tradition has
upheld for literally centuries.
Of course, one could
argue and many Muslims do
that Ijtihad is also
the solution here.
We simply need to go back
and reinterpret the sources
in order to produce new rules.
Ultimately, however, this takes us
back to the problem of authority
for like it or not the classical
tradition will likely retain much
more authority than any
contemporary individual
or movement could hope to muster.
Nor are we guaranteed that new rules
will necessarily be better rules
as we see in the case of so-called
extremist movements today.
Nor will contemporary
interpretations necessarily win the
day by simply declaring
themselves to be right
and classical rules to be wrong.
This recognition, however, of
the basic authority wielded
by the classical tradition need
not bind us to the perspective
or to the perspectives of the
classical jurists themselves
for there was an important
distinction between their statements
of law and their assessments
of fact.
On this distinction classical
rules can be right in terms
of their legal substance
and it is not my contention
that they're necessarily
right, but they could be right.
While at the same time being
wrong when the attempt is
to apply these rules to change
the factual circumstances.
Recognizing this feature
renders any number of the rules
on the books totally
obsolete and inapplicable
to a modern set of circumstances.
Classical deliberations were not
theoretical, but rather practical.
They aim to address the concrete
everyday realities of society.
As such, almost all classical legal
conclusions include an admixture
of law that is the jurists'
interpretations of the sources
and fact of the practical
circumstances the jurists were
seeking to adjudicate.
While the strictly legal dimension
of these rulings might be assumed
to entail an element
of transcendence being presumably
grounded in some interpretation
of scripture the factual
dimensions could not.
To take one example, based on
prophetic precedent contracts
of sale generally entail an implied
warranty with a specified amount
of time to check the
product's integrity.
How much time, however, dependent
on the jurists' factual assessment
of what prevailing circumstances
dictated as fair and reasonable.
In that light the maximum time
allowed for real estate was set
at 36 days and this is the maximum
warranty period that one will find
in classical laws on classical
manuals on Islamic law.
But this 36 day allowance
was clearly not a matter
of permanent law even if the rule
[inaudible] implied warranties was.
And in modern context
where commercial real estate is
extremely complicated this period
could easily be extended to allow
years to test a building's integrity
and such an adjustment would
be perfectly legitimate
as a standard feature
of Islamic law.
We see the importance and
authenticity of this approach
to Islamic law and in exchange
recorded by an old friend of mine
on whom I actually will
my dissertation way back
in the last century.
The 13th century Egyptian jurist
of the [inaudible] school,
Shihab al-Din al-Qarafi and I'm
translating here from the Arabic.
Question, what is the correct view
regarding those rulings upheld
in the school of Maliki, Shafi'i and
the rest which have been deducted
on the basis of habits
and customs prevailing
at the time these jurists
reached these conclusions.
When these customs change
and the practice comes
to indicate the opposite of what it
used to, are the rulings recorded
in the manuals of the jurists
rendered thereby defunct.
It becoming incumbent to issue new
rulings based on the new custom
or is it to be said we
are merely followers
of the independent,
authoritative jurists.
It is thus not our place
to innovate new rulings
as we lack the qualifications
to do so.
Therefore, we issue rulings
according to what we find
in the books handed
down on the authority
of the independent
authoritative jurists.
Answer, holding to rulings that
have been deduced on the basis
of prevailing customs even
after these customs have changed is
a violation of unanimous consensus
and an open display of ignorance
of the religion, end of quote.
Again, almost every area of
Islamic law consists of rules
that include an admixture of legal
interpretations on the one hand
and factual assessments
on the other.
This includes rules in areas ranging
from family law to the status
of non-Muslims, commercial
law, jihad and even aspects
of the criminal law for example,
rules governing apostasy.
In all of these areas
where the rules
of the books reflect
the lived realities
of pre-modern Muslim society
these rules can be adjusted
to modern facts without in
any way violating the sanctity
of Islamic law.
Another major feature
of the classical tradition
is its recognition
of the limits of Islamic law.
This is a difficult point
to make in a modern context
where secular is assumed to take
over where the religious leaves off.
And secular is understood to
be the antithesis of religious.
My point, however, is simply
that Islamic law recognized
that the law itself was not
intended to address all issues.
And that beyond the scope of the
source's jurisdiction other forms
of deliberation, including those
that rely on reason, science,
practical experience, even
perhaps spiritual epiphany could be
legitimately invoked.
To be sure this never
amounted to what we
in the modern west would
identify as secular
for Muslim jurists never
acknowledged the propriety
or proceeding as if
God did not exist.
They did recognize, however,
that Islam as a religion is
broader in scope than sharia.
And that the limits of
sharia do not, therefore,
equal the limits of Islam.
Thus, assuming that sharia did
not address an issue concretely an
approach to that issue that
was grounded say in chemistry
or actuarial science or plain old
mathematics could be perfectly
Islamic even if it was not based
in sharia in the strict sense.
This is the area for which I have
coined the term the Islamic secular
rather than opposing
or even competing
with sharia is simply
complement sharia by recognizing
that in many instances
Muslims cannot rely
on sharia for concrete answers.
In fact, in any number of instances
their reasoning will be generically
indistinguishable from that of
their non-Muslim compatriots.
Take an issue for example,
such as speed limits
or licensing medical doctors, excuse
me or licensing medical doctors.
The most sharia could provide here
would be the value of ensuring
that such policies served the
communal interests of safety,
competence, and the like.
What actually constitutes
safety or competence, however,
in concrete terms could not be
determined on the basis of sharia
for there simply is
nothing in sharia
that could identify 55 miles per
hour as an appropriate speed limit
or three or four or
six years of rotation
as a requirement for
medical licensing.
Rather, in deliberating these
issues, Muslims would have to rely
on the same kinds of considerations
upon which non-Muslims rely physics,
actuarial science, insurance
adjusters, experience and the like.
And this would extend to a
virtually endless list of issues
in the contemporary public
domain from immigration policy
to national healthcare, from
FAA regulations to tenure
and promotion procedures
in our universities.
All of this is extremely
important for at least two reasons.
First, precisely because
things such as speed limits
or building occupancy codes
or national healthcare plans
are not governed by sharia
in the strict sense Muslims
and non-Muslims can be brought
into conversation and
debate over these issues
on a shared intellectual plane.
Sharia in other words, does not
constitute a barrier between Muslims
and non-Muslims when it comes
to debating these issues.
Second, because society is perhaps
more affected on a daily basis
by regulations in the
non-sharia realm than it is
by rules strictly dictated by
sharia, even in a polity governed
by sharia the area of presumed
conflict between Muslims
and non-Muslims might be much
narrower than is commonly presumed.
And the area of what
John Rawls will refer
to as public reason might be much
broader than is commonly assumed.
Attention to the Islamic
secular is also important
to the modern political order
of Muslim states for part
of the problem here is the
tendency on the part of governments
on the one hand and Islamist
movements on the other
to invoke the unassailable
authority of sharia as a means
of raising whatever rules
or policies they propose
beyond critique.
Careful attention to the Islamic
secular meanwhile could confer
at least three distinct advantages.
First, it could insulate Muslim
governments from inflated charges
of violating Islamic law every time
they institute economic, educational
or bureaucratic policies that are
not explicitly dictated by sharia.
Second, it could empower
Muslim communities
to hold their governments to
greater degrees of accountability
by denying these governments
the ability
to wrap their everyday policy in the
unassailable authority of sharia.
Finally, it could contribute to
the domestication of power itself
by forcing power to negotiate its
right to coerce rather than assuming
that Muslim rulers in governments
have some uncontested right
to coerce in the name
of what a friend
of mine would call
God's pious dictator.
I would like to end these incomplete
ruminations on reform in Islamic law
by referring to what remains in
my mind an outstanding problem.
And I'd like to take advantage
of the intellectual
[inaudible] room underscored.
The problem of which I am
speaking is quite simply history.
More specifically, unlike modern
states Islamic law never devised a
mechanism for wiping the
books clean of outmoded,
discarded or discredited rules.
Rather, juristic culture as
a whole oversaw this process
by constantly identifying
and updating what each school
identified as its going opinion.
With the marginalization of this
legacy in modern times, however,
the entire record of every opinion
ever reached lay at the disposal
of the Muslim masses, including
moderate Islamist movements,
the majority of whom are
untrained in the law.
This means that they can
go back and access rules
that have been long
discarded or discredited
by the sharia establishment
and treat these rules
as if they were the going opinion.
And this without the benefit
of knowing the important
distinction between law and fact.
What renders this even
more problematic, however,
is the fact that this rich
and variated [inaudible]
of Muslim juristic opinion
is extremely valuable
in demonstrating both the
pluralistic nature of Islamic law
and the degree of intellectual
boldness and sophistication
that went into Muslim
legal deliberations.
Thus it would be remiss to try
to block access to this very rich
and inspiring legacy and yet this
very access itself poses real
problems and even potential dangers.
Devising a solution to this
problem in my mind will be key
to preserving any gains
that a successful attempt
to reform Islamic law might achieve.
Yet, I must admit that I
remain stymied by this problem,
I'm not sure how to handle it.
In the end, however, whatever
solution the Muslim community
ultimately settles upon one can only
hope that the cure does not turn
out to be worse than
the very disease.
Thank you very much.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Let me
kick off with this question.
As many of you know, Prime Minister
Tony Blair was here last week
to give the Kissinger lecture
on international affairs
and his remarks got a lot of press.
In his remarks Prime
Minister Blair said
that defeating Isis what he insisted
on calling [inaudible] was to quote,
only a necessary beginning
because again to quote,
force alone will not prevail
and the Islamist ideology
has also to be confronted.
So my question to the four of you
is what does Islamic law reform
or to use Intisar's
words, internal critique,
have to do with confronting Islamist
ideology, something that's on a lot
of people's minds right now?
>> Issam M. Saliba: Who would
like to, would you like?
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Deer in the headlights.
Why don't you start Sherman?
>> Sherman A. Jackson: Oh my God.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Oh
Lordy, Lordy, Lordy.
>> Sherman A. Jackson: I
was thinking that, you know,
whoever plans to run for
president should probably try
and answer that question.
I think that there are
a couple of things.
I think that with regard to
Islamic law one of the things
that I think would play
an important role in all
of this is a greater diffusion
of religious literacy
within society at large.
Because it is in some
sense the absence,
the lack of religious literacy
in Muslim society generally
that enables these views
to gain an audience
and to get a multiplier effect.
And, you know, I travel in
the Muslim world more often
than my wife would like, but
one of the things that I --
an impression, just an
impression I've not done any sort
of study or anything like this.
But one of the impressions
that I get is that in a number
of instances sort of official
policy seems to be to sort
of keep public religious discourse
at a minimum as a means of sort
of controlling religion in general.
And I think that what that does
is that sustains a reality,
a very limited religious literacy
and that opens up the way for those
who want to make all kinds
of other outlandish claims,
particularly given the reality of
the internet and things like that
to be much more effective
in that regard.
So I think that one of the keys
to turning this corner is a greater
diffusion of religious literacy
and I', going to be very clear about
what I have in mind in that regard.
I'm not talking about turning
society into a society of clerics,
that's not what I'm
talking about at all.
But there are a number of just
sort of general literacy issues
in Islamic law that could be
very useful and stemming the kind
of extremism and I'm going to
give you just one small example
so that you know that I'm
speaking in concrete terms.
If you have a command in the Quran
or the [inaudible] the
prophet do, do this.
Classical Islamic theory
universally recognizes the fact
that that command can mean
either must do, should do,
may do and this is standard,
this is standard gear.
But for the uninitiated any
command that they might encounter
in the Quran or the Sunni will
represent to them must do.
And this can have far-reaching
implications and effects.
And this is why I think
that greater diffusion
of religious literacy is a key to
turning the corner in this regard.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Thank you.
>> Intisar A. Rabb: I'm going
to say something briefly.
I mean I was sitting here trying
to think of how even to approach
that question with
respect to context here.
What would we -- that
relate to extremists
who commit acts of violence.
What would we say about
the person that blows
up the planned parenthood
office or facility and claims
that they're doing so on the
basis of their Christian values
and aims to support life?
And I think, I mean in addition
to the sort of religious literacy
which I think is on point I mean
one would want for not just those
who may be in communities that may
encounter someone who is likely
to blow up a planned parenthood
office about what the religious --
that the religious requirements
in Christianity do not
support such a thing.
And all of this by analogy
to what's going on in some
of the regions in the Islamic world.
But also that the greater
community, policymakers, educators,
and the like also have this sort
of basic literacy in order not
to by way of buying into the
extremist claims sort of reify it
and create this echo
chamber that results
in policies that are problematic.
So it's a political
problem I suppose more
than one that's directly
related to Islamic law,
but Islamic law certainly
relevant I think
in the educational and policy sense.
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Thank you, Kristen.
>> Kristen A. Stilt:
I would just recently
when you first asked the question
it took me a minute to think
about the connection between the
two because in some ways the kind
of Islamic law reform we're talking
about a little bit here at least
with the criminal and the family
law context is sort of national laws
and what nations do in terms
of their own legal system.
But ideology of course
is boundaryless,
it doesn't respect boundaries, it
doesn't respect national states,
it's a vast, vast question.
And, you know, I think Sherman ended
with something that's right on point
if I could just echo it, which
is that every opinion ever is
at everyone's disposal and that is
as you said, positive and negative.
And that is not something that the
current structures are necessarily
set up to address.
You can't change an internal law
in a country and address this kind
of problem they're connected,
but perhaps by steps.
But it's a much bigger question
that spans places and times.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Absolutely, yeah.
>> Issam M. Saliba: My study
of Islamic law even though I'm not a
Muslim really made me very impressed
with the legal theory that has
been formulated centuries ago.
I mean here you have the 7th,
8th, 9th, 10th century people
who are talking about the
importance of human reason,
human reason not God,
of human reason
in understanding what
God wants to say.
Unfortunately, whatever happened
and this has nothing to do
with Islam has to do with history.
There was some kind of a
blockage, complete blockage.
We have to accept the fact, we
have to admit that what some
of what ISIS is doing has
a root in the traditions.
Now this is not the whole
tradition, but there is some roots
and I think the Muslim community,
especially the intellectual
leaders have to come up and say
that whatever they are
relying on is a portion
that does not represent
the full Islamic tradition.
And this I think would agree with
Sherman teaching the public opinion,
the public Muslim, the
general people what Islam is,
what religion is, true
religion is I think will help.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Let me
raise the question of the Quran
in relation to this conversation.
You know, it's often said
by scholars of the Quran
that only a small proportion
of the Quran contains
explicitly legal content,
yet obviously the Quran continues
to loom very large among
the sources of the law.
So obviously, very large and any
thinking about a reformulation
or reform of Islamic law.
In fact, I would ask in a more
pointed way isn't the conversation
about Islamic law reform
fundamentally a conversation
about the willingness
to reconceptualize
and reinterpret the Quran?
Doesn't that go to the heart
of what we're discussing,
what we're trying to do?
>> Intisar A. Rabb: Sure, one thing
that I can say about that and I have
to be careful because Jane
McAuliffe she was my dean when I was
in Georgetown as a
scholar of the Quran.
But yes, it's been said
that something like 500
out of the some 6,000 plus verses
of the Quran have explicitly
legal content or write content.
But by that scholars making
these claims are looking
at the explicit rules that might
govern things like inheritance,
laws of war, family
law and the like.
But I don't think they mean to
suggest that the overarching values
and lessons in parables
that come out in the rest
of the Quran are not relevant
to Islamic law or sharia
in its broader terms of the law of
ethics, etcetera that are wrapped
up in interpreting
what Islamic law is.
And so it's something that
I think a short answer
to your question is
yes, is the conversation
about Islamic legal change
really a conversation
about reconceptualizing
understandings
of the Quran in the modern world.
I think yes, but I think it's not
with respect to the limited set
of rules but the standards
as well and values
that have always been a
part of the Islamic law mix.
>> Issam M. Saliba: I was thinking
about this question very long time.
That there in the Quran something
that is unquestionable you cannot
interpret one way or the other.
And one of the things that usually
people think about is the adultery
and the adultery has a
punishment that the Quran specify.
How can we change that?
Is there a way to change
that through interpretation?
And I was thinking very deeply about
that until I got to read Al-Muwatta.
Muwatta Imam Malik who wrote it
and it is considered the
first legal book in Islam.
And what caught my attention
is Hijaz that goes to prophet,
a man who came to [inaudible]
before he came [inaudible]
and told him I committed adultery.
What do you expect if the Quran is
saying adultery has to be punished
by death, what should he say?
Well Abu-Bakr told him did
you tell anybody, he said no.
He said go and repent, God
will accept your repentance.
And he went and he wasn't satisfied.
He went to [inaudible] he
asked him the same question
and [inaudible] answered
him the same thing.
Then he went to the prophet
and what did the prophet say?
He turned his face against
from him for three times
and then he continued, this man
continued to want to clean himself.
And then the prophet asked
him to [inaudible] one
of his family and he did.
And he asked, the prophet asked
him is he sick, is he mad,
is there anything, they said no.
And then the prophet was forced
to condemn him to be stoned.
Now this story, I mean
this is coming Imam Malik
and this is you cannot have
more authentic source more
than Al-Muwatta.
And this tells you something that
you can interpret from this story
that even though is immoral
condemnation, the adultery,
it's not necessarily has to be a
legal rule that you as a society
or as a government should apply.
So I think through the
Islamic [inaudible]
in existence there is a lot
of room for improvement.
And I'm not claiming that we
should just wipe away everything
and come back start anew, but there
is a way for the deep thinkers
of Islam to form Islamic
law from within.
Not rely on the declaration
of the human rights or declare
about what we say in the west,
but in their own traditions
there are a lot of things
that have not been consulted.
>> Intisar A. Rabb: I know I said
something here, but could I just
because this actually a case that
features largely in this history
about -- you're referring
to the case of [inaudible].
>> Issam M. Saliba: Yes.
>> Intisar A. Rabb: Who went
to the prophet three times
saying I've committed adultery.
>> Issam M. Saliba: That's right.
>> Intisar A. Rabb: And
was sort of turned away.
And finally the prophet said
fine you committed adultery,
but he didn't say anything
about punishment
and the Quran doesn't say anything
about stoning as a punishment
for adultery that was a Middle
Eastern tradition, perhaps it came
from Jewish law in
the Old Testament.
But it was not in Islamic
punishment it's not in the Quran.
So the townspeople based on that
local tradition ended up stoning him
and in fact, when the prophet
heard about that he said,
if you would have just let him go.
And then there was a huge discussion
after that in the literature
over the centuries
and until this day.
And I'm sure you know this story
about whether the prophet was
advising folks to let [inaudible] go
in his prophetic capacity
and that is the rule,
the rule of doubt essentially
that I talked about
or was it his personal
capacity and he was softhearted.
I think, I mean and the
general interpretation was
that it was the prophetic capacity
and this is actually
the Islamic legal rule
that undergirded this idea
of avoid criminal punishments
in cases of doubt.
But I think your general point is
right and I totally agree with that
that there's a lot of
room for internal review
and lots of room for revising.
>> Issam M. Saliba: This
is my point, this my point.
Why, for example, [inaudible]
doesn't have somebody to come out
and say, yes our tradition,
our tradition allow
for this type of changes.
We are not in need to go
to the United States law
or to the French law,
it's our tradition.
And there is a wealth of great
things in the sharia traditions
that can not only reform Islamic
law, but can make it even better
in my opinion than other laws.
And here I remember what Jackson,
Jackson the Supreme Court,
Robert Jackson about what he said.
>> Sherman A. Jackson: Close.
>> Issam M. Saliba: That's very,
very, very impressive what he said
and he said that the
Islamic law has an amazing,
I mean he used the word amazing
record of accomplishment.
But [inaudible] letting them be
hidden because of our action today.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Well you're
really raising a question
of authority here.
Well you reference
[inaudible], you know,
within Sunni Islam is there a
sufficiently overriding authority
that legal reform could have
any hope of implementation
on a worldwide or a very
large scale or the reform
of Islamic legal thinking.
Sherman, I may have cut you off.
>> Sherman A. Jackson: Well,
I mean I think that, you know,
Muslim countries can, you know,
institute whatever reforms
basically fit the context
of what the political situation
in that particular
country will accommodate.
So terms of formal reforms,
I mean that can take place.
I guess the broader question
is the degree of resonance
that those reforms have among
the population to the extent
that they are accepted as being
sort of legitimate reforms.
And that's a more complicated
question, I think that with regard
to institutions such as [inaudible],
I think one of the things
that we have to be more aware
of in the west is this is
that on the one hand we want
[inaudible] or any other sort
of official sharia establishment,
you know, to take the lead
in instituting some of
these reform measures.
While at the same time not
fully appreciating the extent
to which Alzar's inability
and I'm not picking
on Alzar I'm just using him as
an example, inability to address,
you know, major sort of issues in
society from wealth distribution
to poverty to corruption
to foreign policy.
Their inability to address these
issues undermines the authority
with the masses and in so
doing undermines their ability
or certainly limits their
ability, you know, to have the kind
of authority that could enlist
the assent of the population.
And in that vacuum that's
where many of, you know,
the Islamist movements
come in to fill the void.
So I think that, you know, just
looking at these institutions
in isolation from the
ongoing political realities
of the Muslim world I think it's
sort of naive and it's asking Alzar,
I mean essentially
to do the impossible.
And I think that on the issue
of reinterpretation of the Quran
and I say this in the interest
of trying to move us to a point
where the kinds of
conversation between Islam
and the west can actually
have a greater ability
to actually lead somewhere.
Look, in terms of let's
say this thing on adultery,
the evidentiary burden for
adultery has been I mean almost
impossible to.
>> Issam M. Saliba: Absolutely.
>> Sherman A. Jackson: To
achieve from the beginning.
>> Issam M. Saliba: Absolutely.
>> Sherman A. Jackson: And so
with regard to interpretation,
there's not very much you need
to interpret very much there,
I mean it's almost
impossible to prove.
But what we have to recognize is
this is that many Muslims feel
that what they're being called upon
to do is reconcile Islam with a sort
of hegemonic liberalism
that would basically argue
that well there is no justification
for having any rule
on adultery period.
And what they're being asked
to do is reinterpret the Quran
to the point that there
is no regulation
on something like adultery.
And I think that those,
I mean that kind
of what I would consider extremism
on the other side also preempts a
possibility of meaning conversation.
>> Issam M. Saliba:
Sure [inaudible].
>> Sherman A. Jackson:
But that's [inaudible].
>> Jane McAuliffe: Let's switch
the conversation a little bit here
because I think one of the
other things that we really want
to explore is what are the
engines of change here.
Some of what you had to say Kristen
talked about particular forms of --
particular kinds of
reform, who started them,
where are things bubbling up, where
we actually getting some action.
Intisar you too when you
talked about the code in Iran.
How is it happening on the ground
can you speak to that a little bit?
>> Kristen A. Stilt: Yeah
and I think just to pick
up on the comment just
about Alzar to be clear.
I think it's very important
to segment these conversations
into substantive areas of the law.
Alzar is very permissive
on Islamic finance,
but has not been a very
strong supporter of changes
that have been requested
by women's groups
to enhance the rights
of women for example.
So I think we want to segment out
these kind of conversations and say,
when it comes to inheritance
law which is quite specific
in the Quran, you see that
really holding on even in a place
like Tunisia where a lot
of the family law has become move
towards a much more egalitarian
model with Islamic justifications.
But the inheritance portion has
remained pretty, pretty tight.
Whereas, of course, in
criminal law very few countries
as Intisar said apply
classical criminal law.
So looking at different
substantive areas
of the laws gives us another lens
on how things change, you know,
Islamic law is not consistently
applied the same way in every place.
There's extreme variations
depending on the country and even
within countries in a
place like Malaysia.
But then to the point of where
the change comes from, you know,
I think the bottom up is
a very important place
and that's not always a good thing.
But it's sometimes a very good
thing when we look at, you know,
activism around women's issues
for example and other areas
in which activists are driving and
demanding change and finding ways
to justify it and trying
to get someone
in authority to agree with them.
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Yeah, would you agree
to that mechanism that
was working in the?
>> Intisar A. Rabb: I think
bottom-up is a part of it
and I think top-down and lateral are
also parts of it, important parts,
meaning that civil society
groups, human rights groups and the
like they may come
with arguments seeking
to identify economic disparities,
gender injustices and the like.
And then perhaps the jurists
as in the criminal law case
or the professors at the secular
university who draw on both Islamic
and state law, which is still
generally based on European codes
in the Muslim world tend to come up
with arguments to push the envelope,
push the laws to change much in
the way it happens in this country.
You look at the civil
rights movement and we had,
I mean it's a question about social
change or legal change right.
Where you have a confluence of the
civil rights movement and people
in the trenches, as well as
a willingness on the part
of the legislators
and the government
to listen perhaps together
with economic --
with it falling into
the economic interest.
I think a lot of that is happening
around critical justice
reforms today.
So I think it takes all sides,
but I think what Sherman Jackson
just pointed to about the necessity
of bringing the conversation
to a level of sophistication
and constant engagement
in identifying
and continuing those conversations
with those various
sides is important.
So I think it's both
horizontal and vertical.
>> Jane McAuliffe: What about
the possibility of interference
and I'll pose it this way.
What right does a non-Muslim
institution like the Library
of Congress have to
even raise these issues,
I mean or to hold a
conference like this?
That it really is a matter of
do the efforts of, you know,
western universities, think tanks,
NGOs to foster discussion
of Islamic law reform.
Do they help or do they
hinder efforts undertaken
in the Muslim world?
>> Intisar A. Rabb: I don't want
to keep talking, but that's okay.
I mean it's a great
self-reflective question, you know,
what are we doing, what
are we talking about.
I always tend to think
that I mean to the extent
that we can educate ourselves
and other students or uses
of the library or policymakers to
the extent that we all interact
in this world, which is shrinking
and where we as I alluded
to before I think need
also to be educated.
It's not just the Muslims who
need to have some literacy
about their religion and what
it permits and doesn't permit
and how it can be used as a
positive force in society.
But it's also those outside of the
Muslim world, it's non-Muslims,
it's lawyers, it's
policymakers and to that extent,
I think there's a very
significant role.
This is extremely important
and I'm happy to be part
of this conversation to help us
better understand and grapple with
and raise these questions
that relate
to Islamic law and legal change.
>> Issam M. Saliba: What is
wrong I think for us here
in the west is we want to impose
or think that our way of life
or thinking [inaudible]
has to prevail.
We have to understand that in the
Islamic tradition there is great
possibility and great
treasure that has to be used
for any changes to happen.
But the way it has been happening
nowadays is we come to them and say,
human rights, declaration of human
rights rather than saying what is
in your own tradition that
would lead to the same result.
Helping them thinking
through their own traditions,
their own heritage
and there is a lot.
>> Kristen A. Stilt: So I think
this conversation is critical
and I think not to
have it is a mistake
because it's basically saying,
you have your conversation we'll
have ours, we don't have anything
in common with each other.
>> Issam M. Saliba:
No, no, no I'm saying.
>> Kristen A. Stilt: No, I'm
supporting you, I'm supporting you.
This conversation is crucial,
but also just to nuance
that a little bit.
Muslim majority countries
have adopted many
of the international human
rights treaties and people
in those countries believe
that they are entitled
to those rights as well.
And so for us to be
concerned about there being,
it's good to be concerned
about imposition,
but it's also I think important
to say you want that too.
And we're part of a big conversation
and maybe how you think about it
or justify it or reach
certain points you might go
through a different thought process.
But when people are standing up and
saying, we want the same rights,
you know, our country
has signed this.
Pushing their countries as
women's groups have done
to drop the reservations
to CEDAW that say,
no except for Islamic
law then we don't have
to adhere to these rights.
I think we want to see that
and recognize that and say
that we're part of
one big conversation
and that it's important
to have this here today.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Your
thoughts on that Sherman?
>> Sherman A. Jackson: Yeah,
I mean look I think it's
important to keep talking.
And I do think that and I
mean that very seriously.
And I do think that there is a
certain danger of people sort
of sitting around talking
to themselves in a manner
that those conversations are never
open to a sort of critical gaze
from another perspective.
And I think that works on both
sides of the conversation.
I think at the same time,
I mean these conversations
can be hegemonic.
They can start off
from premises that sort
of basically turn the conversation
into have you stopped
beating your wife yet.
Whereby, the other side can only
sort of continually apologize itself
into more ever deeper holes.
And I think that that kind of
conversation has to be avoided.
But there's a very important
role for conversations like this
because I think that -- I
Kristen alluded to it a bit.
Without conversation we
don't even know those areas
in which there is actual
or possible agreement.
And I think that with more and
more conversation that's likely
to be further flushed out.
And I think that the
real key is, you know,
how do we have these conversations,
how do we sustain these
conversations, but how do we do
so in a way that they
don't turn hegemonic.
>> Jane McAuliffe: We've
got 15 minutes left
and I have promised the
panelists that I would ask them
to ask each other any questions
that have occurred to them
as they listen to each other.
And I also am going to
point to a bit of a dilemma.
I have questions from the audience,
which unfortunately are illegible
because they are blue ink
against a blue background.
So I'm really struggling
to get them.
I'm going to pass these
questions to the panelists to see
if their eyes are working
any better than mine.
But if they start to read a question
and you recognize it as yours
by all means, you know,
you may stand up
and give some clarification
of the question.
But we've got a little
technical difficulty here.
But as I pass these
out are there questions
that you have of each other.
Go ahead.
>> Kristen A. Stilt: I do.
Something I want to add Professor
Saliba and Professor Jackson.
So Sherman, you said when customs
and habits change and to me
that raises the question
of who decides when customs
and habits change and you mentioned
Nasr Hamid Abu Zayd and his views.
And one of his views was
that economics have changed
and inheritance -- there should
be an egalitarianism inheritance
that was not widely accepted.
So custom and habits changing
that in itself of course is a test
of fear who decides and I was
wondering if you had a thought
about that as you were talking
about how [inaudible] updated?
>> Sherman A. Jackson: Yeah,
I think the custom is a
double-edged sword in this sense.
That on the one hand it clearly
changes, but on the other hand
in a sense there can
be no single entity
that can determine that change.
Because part of what renders
custom custom is the very fact
that it's unowned.
>> Kristen A. Stilt: Right.
>> Sherman A. Jackson: So
for example where I grew
up in Philadelphia the custom
was guys wear one earring
in the left ear never
in the right ear.
Over a period of time the
custom changes so that
and only females wore two earrings
and now there's a custom
guys wear two earrings.
Now who determined that, you know,
that was okay against
the old, nobody knows.
But it's in a sense
Kristen precisely the fact
that nobody knows is
what renders it a custom.
>> Kristen A. Stilt: Right.
>> Intisar A. Rabb: Yeah.
>> Kristen A. Stilt: That there
wasn't a law hinging on it?
>> Sherman A. Jackson: No.
>> Kristen A. Stilt:
[Inaudible] difference right.
>> Sherman A. Jackson: No,
no and so I think that,
I mean what you have are jurists who
will make this claim on the basis
of custom and that claim will
either resonate or it won't.
So for example, my own best
friend Al-Kharafi talks
about how the custom
had changed in terms
of the formulae used for divorce.
And he was arguing against his
Malaki fellow jurists saying
that this stuff that
you find in the books
of Maliki is no longer applicable
because the custom has changed.
Now some of them agree, some
of them don't end this kind
of thing is argued out.
But I don't think that there's
any single entity that has sort
of formal authority to say,
this is now custom that is not.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Okay.'
>> Kristen A. Stilt: And someone
like Nasr Hamid Abu Zayd says
[inaudible] and then is rebuffed,
that's the nature of customs.
>> Issam M. Saliba: Yeah, I would
say here there is two issues.
Either there is a change that
come like in the common law,
then things have changing gradually
and then the judges are articulating
this change and become law.
In the Islamic tradition it's
not the judges who articulate
but scholars, which unfortunately we
didn't have since the 10th century.
So this is one way.
>> Sherman A. Jackson:
But not even scholars.
>> Issam M. Saliba:
Well in the past years.
>> Sherman A. Jackson:
But the problem,
I mean even Kharafi says this,
scholars may hold something
to be customary because
it's in the books.
And [inaudible] saying
you have to go
and see what's customary in society.
>> Issam M. Saliba: But
articulating that how
in the common law the judges
articulate that change.
That the judges are not making
the changes they are articulating
the changes.
So this is one way.
The other way is through
the people deciding
and how the people deciding nowadays
is through whatever form they want.
And this point for example
specifically Muhammad Iqbal
who is a great Muslim
scholar and a great thinker
and a great [inaudible] he
mentioned that in his writing
when they were thinking about
creating books Pakistan.
I don't think he had in mind at all
Pakistan like the present Pakistan
and he was a devout Muslim
committed to his religion.
So these are two ways.
There is nothing wrong about the
people deciding through elections
or whatever, but this has
to be articulated by someone
who has some kind of credentials
that Muslims believe in the public
and I don't know where to find that.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Well if
we're going to keep the faith
of this audio I think we've got
to try and tackle the decipherment
of a few of these question.
>> Issam M. Saliba: Yeah.
>> Kristen A. Stilt:
Can you read yours?
I can read mine.
>> Jane McAuliffe: All right, why
don't you take the start Kristen?
>> Kristen A. Stilt: Do
you want me to read it?
>> Jane McAuliffe: Yeah.
>> Kristen A. Stilt: What advice
would you give to policymakers
who are not Islamic scholars
yet wish to be effective
at reconciling religious
and cultural traditions
with governments, human
rights obligations
under international treaties,
particularly on the rights
of women such as CEDAW?
>> Jane McAuliffe: Well go ahead.
>> Kristen A. Stilt:
It's a great question.
I teach a class that tries to
deal with this and in looking
for materials I've found
this fantastic report
by a group called Massawa
[phonetic], a group of women
that started as sisters in
Islam Malaysia and expanded.
And as I mentioned before,
a lot of countries will say
to CEDAW we can't do this, we can't
do that because of Islamic law.
And Massawa has a report that
basically takes apart every claim
and says yes you can
and let me show you why.
Yes you can and they're
speaking to the CEDAW commission
and they say don't let these
countries get away with this
under the guise of Islamic
law, it's really patriarchy
and we'll show you how you
can get there from here.
And that's fascinating and following
a group like that allows you then
to work under the rubric
or in conjunction
with someone who's trying
to operate internally.
And yet at the same time be
supportive of their endeavor.
So I've put that out there as
one example where that kind
of conversation is taking place
within in an internal community,
but they're taking to task there
are other countries that are trying
to use these exceptions as
really what they say is a guise
for just your patriarchy.
>> Intisar A. Rabb:
I have a question
that I think is directed
at Sherman Jackson.
It doesn't say it but.
>> Sherman A. Jackson:
[Inaudible] Intisar Rabb.
>> Intisar A. Rabb: Is law reform
inhibited by different degrees
of passion analogous
to gun control here
where arguably the majority mildly
in favor of controls is thwarted
by a passionate anti-control
minority?
>> Sherman A. Jackson:
Yeah, I mean I think
that that's definitely the
case, I mean whatever the sort
of prevailing sensibilities,
passions in society are will
have an effect on the extent
to which reform can
actually take place.
You know Muslim reformers are
human beings in parts of society
like everybody else and,
you know, proposing this
or that idea can be
easier or harder depending
on the circumstances
that they're facing.
I think the real question, however,
is you know how much authority does
the proposer of a particular reform,
how much authority do they possess.
And here I'll go back to a point
that Kristen made earlier and say
that we have to differentiate,
I mean there are different
kinds of authority.
And let me just give you one
example of what I'm talking about.
Most of us in this room
are probably old enough
to remember the assassination
of Anwar Sadat in 1981.
In 1997, the group that assassinated
Sadat basically came out
and renounced political violence.
Now there have been all kinds
of meetings and back and forth
between them and the government
and government officials
and [inaudible], etcetera
all of them failed.
It was when the leaders of this
group, however, decided on their own
that we're going to
renounce political violence,
then they were able to sell that to
a much broader segment of society.
So they had a form of authority that
even, you know, jurists and clerics
of [inaudible] might not have
had in that particular context.
So I think that there are lots
of different players and we have
to be sensitive to the type
of authority that is possessed
and the type of authority that is
needed to address specific groups.
What type of authority is needed
let's say to address ISIS right now?
Is it [inaudible] or
is it the [inaudible]?
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Intisar do you have?
>> Intisar A. Rabb: Another
question here is how to tell when,
how do you tell when consensus
on legal change is pervasive
enough to be authoritative?
And it seems -- this question
seems linked to this question
of authority, but also to that
earlier question about, you know,
just how does legal change happen.
And I will only say this
that I think that every --
we have to be careful to not speak
in excessive generality even
though Islamic law is something
that in some ways can be amorphous
and cross-border transnational.
But I mean there are states
and different manifestations
of Islamic law and
I think one element
of authority is state
authority to control
and monopolize violence
and other forms of law.
And that's one easy way
of telling when a method
of change is authoritative
you've convinced your legislators
through all of these different
actors that might do the convincing.
As we talked about
before the horizontal
and the vertical to
create legal change.
But I mean there of course is a
social, religious aspect as well
for those who follow
Islamic law that is private
and there may be elements
of infusing or degrees
to which you can infuse more of
the values of Islamic law relevant
to the context in which you
live and that manifests itself
in some changes in Islamic law.
The extent of authority I think
then depends on the extent
to which these individuals
follow an authoritative figure
or school of thought.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Probably have
time for one last question, Issam.
>> Issam M. Saliba:
I think [inaudible].
>> Kristen A. Stilt: Ayan
[phonetic] [inaudible].
>> Issam M. Saliba: Ayan in
her recent book [inaudible]
for reforming Islam,
including Islamic laws focused
on the afterlife as
I don't know what --
as an obstacle to everyday
secular life.
Your comment.
If this is what I understand.
I personally from my reading
and study of Islamic law
and Islamic tradition, I think
this is a great tradition.
It has a great potential
for correcting what we see
wrong here from within.
And I don't think that
only can it be said to be
for the afterlife it can
be for this life as well
because there is a tremendous
principle and good traditions
in the Islamic history that is not
being even known to most Muslims.
For example, when you read, you
know, [inaudible] what he said
about [inaudible] getting into the
church of [inaudible] in Jerusalem
and the time of the [inaudible] came
the patriarch invited him to pray
in the church and he refused.
Why, he said probably some of my
Muslim in the future will come
and say this is where [inaudible]
prayed and we want to convert that.
He went outside and
prayed in front of the.
Now some Muslim, scholars even
they say this is not a true story,
but whether this is true story
or not it represents a great
part of the Islamic heritage.
How can you [inaudible]
with what ISIS is doing
by destroying the churches
in [inaudible].
And this is what I'm saying,
I mean we have to go back
to the Islamic traditions themselves
and there is a tremendous,
tremendous possibilities there
to correct what I think is wrong
today with the likes of ISIS.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Well maybe we'll
let that be the last word in terms
of our open panel discussion,
but I'm going to go to the podium
and introduce our very final
speaker of the morning.
But before I do that may I ask you
to join me in thanking our panel.
[ Applause ]
And now I would like to ask Dr. Mary
Jane Deeb to come to the podium.
She is chief of the African
and Middle East Division here
at the Library of Congress
and she's going
to wrap this all up in a few words.
I mean it's an impossible task that
we have asked Dr. Mary Jane Deeb
to undertake, but I know you
will enjoy her final remarks.
Thank you.
>> Mary Jane Deeb: Thank
you Jane and thank you.
I want first to thank the Law
Library, its acting law librarian,
Rebecca Schaffer, for hosting it and
the law librarians who organized it
and who invited me to this
discussion, [inaudible],
Kimberly Zellars and all the others.
So thank you for being here.
My division is cohosting this event
and so I'm delighted to be here just
to make a few closing remarks.
There are a few and I'm not going
to try to put everything together
because it's been very
exciting and I'm going
to leave you with their ideas.
I'm going to wrap up
the program today,
I will just make a few comments.
The speakers have made fascinating
and thought-provoking presentations
and have challenged
many of the stereotypes
that people have in
mind about sharia.
So let me add my two cents to the
discussion, not as a legal scholar
which I'm not, but as a
political scientist which I am.
From that perspective that
is of a social scientist,
I approach all law whether western
or Islamic as interpretation.
It is the interpretation of
religious text, ethical principles,
philosophical thesis
and/or cultural traditions.
Islamic law as we have heard today
or sharia is the interpretation
of mainly three things.
The Quran, which is a
sacred religious text.
The Hadith, which is verbally
transmitted sayings of the prophet.
And the Sunnah, which
is a reported record
of the prophecy reads and teachings.
In addition, there is [inaudible],
which are the customs and traditions
of the many Muslim
societies around the world.
Again, as a social scientist I have
to categorize, to classify things.
So how to classify Islamic law in
order to be able to analyze it.
The issue I raise is an issue which
is important in the Muslim world
and that is whether Sharia can be
classified as sacred law and so
by definition unchanging.
Example, you cannot really
change the 10 Commandments
or is it secular law,
which is man-made and,
therefore, can be changed.
Professor Schacht maintains that
because Islamic law is derived
from the Quran, which is a
sacred text and I'm quoting him,
Islamic law is a particularly
instructive example of a sacred law.
He argues that the individuality and
I think Professor Jackson referred
to it, the individuality
of legal subject matter
and religious norm is additional to
the [inaudible] variety of legal,
ethical and ritual rules,
which is typical of sacred law.
But others, such as Nasr Hamid Abu
Zayd whom we've been talking about,
have argued that once the
revelations reach human beings
and were interpreted by them
they were no longer in the sphere
of the sacred, but rather
in that of the mundane.
He stated that Quranic
interpretation I'm quoting him,
was one of the tools
used in intellectual,
social, and political struggles.
For him sharia cannot be considered
sacred or consequently unchangeable.
It is unarguably man-made
having been created by jurists
and Muslim scholars
over the centuries.
The history of Islamic law seems
to lean towards Abu Zayd's view
whom we have just discussed.
The Sunnah existed in pre-Islamic
times and meant then a body
of customs, beliefs and
traditions later in Islamic came
to be associated as Muhammad's
reported conducts and sayings.
But as you have heard, there
were competing views and reports
in the prophet's sayings and doings
and the Muslim jurists needed
to interpret them in
order to create a body
of cohesive legal doctrines
and practices.
[Inaudible] the customs
and traditions was also
taken into consideration.
They developed early on
the four major schools
of Islamic jurisprudence, the
[inaudible] that we have talked
about and with the founding
of the Hanafi School
with [inaudible] Abu Hanafi.
And then there was [inaudible]
who established the Malaki
School of Jurisprudence.
And Muhammad [inaudible] who
established Shafi'i School.
And finally came the fourth
jurist Ahmed Ibn Hambal
who established the Hanbali School
and you must have heard a lot
about the Hanbalis and the impact
of that school of jurisprudence
on Islamists, radical
Islamists today.
In other words, from the very early
days of Islam there was debate
as we have talked about
regarding Islamic law,
it was not static as
sacred law would be.
But instead, it was dynamic,
changing and evolving.
And at the end there was
no consensus of the jurists
on all aspects of law,
hence the emergence
of these four schools
of jurisprudence.
In addition, through the divergences
between these four schools
of sharia there exists another
perhaps even more important
that between the two major branches
of Islam, the Sunni and the Shia,
the approach of Shiism to
[inaudible] is somewhat different
from that of the Sunnis as they have
their own school of jurisprudence.
There's the Ja'fari
school, the school was named
after [inaudible] Ja'fari in the
8th century, the religious imam.
By the way, since 1959
the Ja'fari School
of Jurisprudence has been recognized
as the fifth school of jurisprudence
by the [inaudible] in Cairo.
Among Shiites the door
of Ijtihad seems
to be slightly more open whilst
the door of Ijtihad and we have,
Professor Jackson has
been talking about it.
The door of Ijtihad among Sunnis
seems to be somewhat closed,
although you know not
operationally closed,
but not theoretically closed.
This in terms of Shiism allows
the [inaudible] to make judgments
and to issue rulings
on legal matters
and to interpret the
[inaudible] of religion
and the principles of sharia.
Shiites accept, again there's
a difference between Shiites
and Sunnis when we talk
about reforming Islamic law we
should be clearer on those things.
The Shiites accept only the
interpretation of law based
on the Sunnah concerning the family
of the prophet and his descendants,
the successors and not
necessarily the [inaudible],
the people around the prophet.
Furthermore, Shiites will accept
the interpretation of law only
if validated by the imam.
And one of the pillars of Shiism
is the imamate or the succession
of the prophet, which is not
really acceptable to Sunnis.
And then you have other Muslims with
varying approaches to Islamic law,
such as the Ismaili whose
legal system is based
on the [inaudible] Islam,
the pillars of Islam.
But they hold that there are
seven not five pillars of Islam
that includes the [inaudible],
the devotion to the imam Ja'fari
[inaudible], again he's back.
[Inaudible] ritual purity, which
somehow [inaudible] the Sunnis
because they're not
comfortable with the concept
of an imamate, [inaudible].
And then there is the [inaudible],
one of the main branches
of the Muslim [inaudible] who are
to be found in Iman for example,
as well as in North Africa,
Libya, Algeria, Tunisia.
We just had a group of
[inaudible] from Algeria came
and gave us their publications
and told us
about the work they're doing there,
which I immediately said okay,
you know, bring in your publications
we need to see those as well.
And [inaudible] also
found in East Africa.
They also have a concept of the
imamate, but somewhat different
from that of the Shiites.
The imam is elected secretly
by council of prominent laymen
or by sheikhs and then
proclaimed in public.
Often the eligibility is limited
to a single tribe or even a family.
However, the concept
of several imams
in different regions
is also allowed.
That's interesting when we're
talking about the state for example
as we were referring to earlier.
So one is a discussion such
as the one we've had today,
so important to political
scientists.
Well first, as it was
pointed out by the speakers
because Islamic law focuses on
the organization of the state.
As we have seen concepts
of the caliphate
and the imamate are critical to our
understanding what Muslim rebels
such as ISIS or the
Qaeda are calling for.
They're calling for the
caliphate, but not all of them.
And Islamic law also focuses
on the organization of society
and we had Professor
Stilt talk about it.
And we have seen with the discussion
on women and family law and again,
the ISIS [inaudible]
these groups are claiming
that they know how society should
be organized that they know.
And somehow those who fail to
follow the sharia according
to ISIS should be punished
and [inaudible] we've seen
quite clearly on television.
And thirdly, this discussion is
important to social scientists
because we are discussing change,
reform, modernization as a way
to address the challenge
posed by these
and other groups demanding
change in Muslim society.
So the problem with these
three reasons I've given is
that there is no single
answer to any of these issues.
And in fact, there may
be many contradictions.
So going back to the dichotomy
of sacred versus secular low
for instance, how can there
be reform or modernization
or even change of sacred law,
sacred law should be, you know,
by definition perfect, immutable
if not, how can it be sacred.
And this is certainly the position
of the most conservative groups
and of the radical Islamist
groups such as ISIS.
This is why they do not
want change, it is sacred,
it is untouchable you
do not make changes.
Second, when we talk about change
and reform of sharia what exactly,
what school of jurisprudence
are we focusing on?
That of the [inaudible],
the Shiites,
[inaudible] for instance introduce
a number of changes in the concept
of the state and the imamate and the
role of the clergy and the state.
Are we addressing the Ja'fira
School of Jurisprudence for example
or are we focusing primarily
on Sunni Islam and if so, why?
Thirdly, when we discuss
the concept of the state
as you've all been discussing today,
there is really no clear agreement
of what is the best
form of the state.
The imamate and the
caliphate are not the same.
Also the process historically
of selecting Islamic leaders
as you know has been a very bloody
business and continues to be so.
There is no agreement across the
Muslim world on either process
or representation and
I'm saying this
with qualifications,
but should there be.
And with regards to social
organization, women, the family,
as was pointed out with Professor
Stilt, there is so much variation.
In fact, over the past 1,400 years,
since the beginning of Islam,
there has not been uniformly
applicable laws throughout the
Muslim worlds regarding
the family, women,
social organizations, society.
In fact, look at societies with
predominantly Muslim populations.
Indonesia for example,
Nigeria is another example,
Saudi Arabia have all
very different patterns
of social organization
and family relations.
It is tradition, it is
customs, worldviews that seem
to have had a greater impact in
the final analysis than sharia law.
Okay, I am sticking my neck out
in all this, but I claim ignorance
but I'm only a political scientist.
Then again my question is what is it
that we really are trying to change?
Is it customary law, are we
talking about human rights,
what part of Islamic sharia,
which groups are we trying
to affect and to change?
And as was raised, who is the we, I
mean is it we here, is it we there,
is it one particular group,
is it one particular country,
is it one particular authority.
And I am not going to present any
answer I'm just raising questions
from one perspective and
I'm leaving it at that.
So thank you very much and
thank you all for being here
and this panel was wonderful and
let us give them all a big clap
because they've done
a fantastic job.
And thank you Jane for
moderating it so well.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.